[Music]
hey samuel leeds here
happy sunday evening i usually take a
bit of time out on a sunday to
answer questions on youtube to youtube
so this is what i'm gonna be doing now
so from last week i had some great
questions i wish i could do
answer all of them on youtube i try my
best to answer as many as i can
we had a question from simon lee he said
i am from slovenia and
oh my god nobody doesn't even want to
hear about the lease option agreement
i'm trying now for three months just
can't go
okay simon lee i feel your pain i
really do feel your pain there could be
two things going on
number one could be you're not speaking
to enough people sometimes people say to
me you know i spoke to so many agents i
spoke to so many
landlords and everyone says no and i'll
ask them how many have you actually
spoken to
oh i'm not sure maybe maybe 10 or 20 no
maybe 10
or 20. come on how many and it's
actually like five or six
so it might be that you need to speak to
more people
but probably more likely than that it's
probably that you're saying the wrong
things because if you're saying the
wrong things
you can speak to a thousand people and
they'll all say no so when it comes to
lease option agreements
the first thing you need to do is you
need to investigate their situation
ask them questions because you can't
just pitch a lease option agreement to
somebody without knowing their situation
it might not be any good for them
so once you know that okay i've asked
some questions the least option would be
really good for this person
check check that's number one number two
is before you offer them a lease option
agreement that should be a last resort
should first try and get like tell them
tell them to rent it out themself
you should tell them offer them offer
them different options i call this
on my crash course i talk about this in
detail and i teach you how to exhaust
their options
and when you run out of options and they
need a lease option agreement then you
offer it and you need to offer in a very
specific kind of way
so um simon old to just if you can get
yourself down to the crash course i'm
happy to teach you
and show you exactly what to say but i
hope that alone is helpful
um please keep me posted and when you
get your first deal don't forget to
comment and let me know braden
johnstone says can you tell me anything
about the differences
in laws in new zealand do you have any
experience
i've never been to new zealand and i
haven't got any properties in
new zealand right i don't know braden
about that um
i'm planning at some point i'm visiting
though because i haven't been to
australia either
i wanna you know my planners my plan is
to do a world tour
where i'm just gonna go to like all
these different countries in all these
different continents
and maybe take 25 000 pounds in each
country and and
my plan is to invest it in each country
and if the country is really bad to
invest and i'm like oh no
then i'll i'll i'll do a video about it
and say this country
sucks to invest and i'll keep my 25
grand for england
if the country is really good i'll
invest it and i'll rate each country out
of 10. that's kind of my plan and new
zealand if
if i do do that well if you guys like
the idea let me know
but if i do do that new zealand will
definitely be on the list and i'll
hopefully be able to answer your
question better
bernard says in regards to your recent
trip
to new york and the north west region of
the united states
what were the core differences between
real estate investing in the uk
versus the us which aspects were harder
in the us
and which were easier thank you from the
us um thanks so much for your question
i think that for me the the big
attraction to the us the thing that was
that
just blew my mind was the fact that i
met so many people that were buying
houses
for like 20 30 grand they were spending
20 30 grand doing them up so all in now
they're like 40 50 60 000
in but then the houses were worth over
100 grand
they were and then they were selling
them and making
serious serious cash lots of class
cash for buying and selling you see in
the uk
if you buy a house for 40 grand and you
spend 20 grand on it and you put 16 all
together
if you do it right it might be worth 70
80 grand
but not like 120 not like in the states
so
that was really quite exciting to me i
wanted to do some flips out there
um the things that were harder was
i'm not 100 on the
agents as in it was more difficult just
to get appointments in england i find
that when you book a viewing your book a
viewing
it's in whereas in the states people
kept cancelling viewings not showing
because i hadn't confirmed enough
so i i personally find the uk the agents
easier to deal with but that might
because i'm just used to the agents
also the uk because it's a small island
everything's close by
so you don't have to drive around that
much and because it's a small island as
well
i think things you can be more confident
that things are going to rent
maybe so that's my that's my thoughts i
mean i wasn't i was only there a week
i'd love to go back but yeah uk versus
us
both are good just in different ways
okay next question paul anthony says
is 64 too old to get involved also see
you on the next birmingham crash course
uh
paul 64 is definitely not too old to get
involved
um we've had 72 year olds coming down to
the crash course and they've
loved it and gone and done deals um so
look forward to seeing you there
final question jack farquhar
oh geez i'm really struggling to
pronounce their names i am sorry but the
question's great
what do you look out for in a good
property management company both single
and
multi-layer if you're getting a property
manager
for a multi-let hmo it's really
important that they specialize in
multi-let's don't get a high street
agent
to manage your hmo find a specialist you
can find them on google or spare room
um for a for a single let
it's just a case of making sure that
they're uh i usually ring them
beforehand and i'll even sometimes
pretend to be a tenant and i'll say hey
what properties have you got
available and just see do they answer
the phone quickly how do they treat me
or they're friendly professional
first thing second thing is do they do
all the right checks
what do they charge they shouldn't be
charging more than about ten percent
management
um you know so it i i with a single
it's easy with a hmo it's more difficult
they've got to be specialists and
i'll usually want a recommendation as
well i want to find an investor that's
used them before and ask them so great
question
hope that's helped samuel leeds i have
been you've been awesome
thank you so much for your questions um
ask some more if you've got niggling
property questions comment below
i'll do my best to answer as many as i
can also please do connect with me on
social media
i'm on instagram instagram's like one of
my new favorite platforms
we have a facebook group which is called
property investors with samuel leeds
connect with me on the facebook group
follow me on instagram
stay tuned and i hope to see you at
property investors crash course upcoming
very soon as well
all the details in that are below i'll
see you next time thanks so much
you